game one of the national league division
series between the miami marlins and the
atlanta braves of course this year in a
shortened season division foes met 10
times
and a 6-4 advantage for the atlanta
braves this year max freed 7-0 a 225 era
he also made a couple of day starts and
he was 1-0 180 era in those starts john
bertie a guy that not a lot of people
have heard of but man this guy can fly
and on three pitches he gets john birdie
down on strikes great start for max free
that'll allow garrett cooper to reach
base and now brian anderson and the
cleanup spot stands in
there's 95 and a swing and a miss an 11
pitch 11 strike inning at six foot five
sandy alcantara and sandy's supremely
talented this guy is a stud ronald acuna
who is ofer against alcantara has been
to the plate ten times against him has
no hits one strike pitch fastball on the
outside corner hit in the air right
field side deep got a chance to go that
ball is gone for ronald acuna
it's another lead off home run
he hit it to the right center field
bullpen and it's one to nothing braves
in the first inning you always get a
sense that he got a hold of one because
he will stand and admire it he may have
hit it over the bullpen because that
went a long way to the opposite field
great start here's the heart and soul of
this miami marlins team miguel rojas
and he hammers one to left field this
game is going to be tied miguel rojas
cranks one out
and it's a 1-1 game in the second well
if you're going to be a leader that's
one way to lead by example that was an
absolute blast up there in the crawford
boxes of left field a minute man so
they're at the corners with one out now
and it brings up garrett cooper
pulled on the ground pass to diving
riley and the marlins have taken the
lead
around second there goes birdie into
third he's gonna get the wave home two
will score and the marlins have taken a
3-1 advantage in the third boy the
marlins piecing it together here in the
third inning here is anderson now freed
getting into some trouble there's a 3-1
hard hit into center field down for a
base hit
cooper will get the turnaround third
here comes the throw it's going to be
cut off and it's 4-1 miami a three-run
frame pieced together
by four base hits for miami they've got
a three-run advantage back to the top
and a cunos
not that obviously well ronald acuna jr
has been through this before with the
marlins
and
now the umpires are going to get into it
alcantara and acuna were getting near
one another
ron washington the third base coach and
former manager has to settle lacuna down
you're like just go to first what's
wrong you can't get thrown out here
right here but let me tell you 97 off
the
hip hip
here comes marcel ozuna first pitch
slider bang through the whole left side
of base hit pass to diving anderson
acuna turns second that one gets all the
way to the wall chased down by dickerson
ronald waved around third coming to the
plate here comes the relay head first
slide he's safe marcel ozuna with an rbi
double and the braves cash in that hit
batsman it's four to two
but interesting defensive alignment for
ozuna
they were way off the line i guess
assuming that anything hit to left is
going to hit the crawford boxes and not
go anywhere
bottom half of the third 4-2 miami
one on two out pitch coming
rope down the left field line that's in
for it that will round to the boards in
the left field corner scoring easily is
ozuna darno heading to second slides in
safely head first gives the mix it up
signal to his teammates it's a 4-3 game
on a rocket double by darneau well the
braves need max freed in the in the game
again
no time for payback right here
there'll come a time for it
but we need max reid to pitch deeper
into this ball game and keep it close
lewis brenson hits the first pitch on
the ground to a diving all beast gets up
throws and
got him ozzy shading him up the middle
right-handed batter
ground ball hit
on the first base side of second looked
like it would sneak through but ozzie
with a beautiful diving pickup freed
works to chad wallach
wallock towards second and it's caught
by albies back-to-back sparkling
defensive plays by ozzy albee's for the
braves two down to the fourth freeman
coming up and garcia coming out of the
pen
go ahead run on base for freeman
freeman rolls one over to the right side
birdie's got it he'll fling to second
the slide from acuna is not in time the
throw was that's a big first out riley
advances to third freeman is safe on the
fielder's choice
that's a huge play right there well
here's the rbi leader of the atlanta
braves marcel ozuna 2-2 pitch
line drive down the left-field line
that's in for a base hit tracking it
toward the corners dickerson comes up
firing back toward the play to run
scores the game is tied
rbi again
for marcel ozuna who invented the mix it
up
gesture that the braves have used all
year and he comes up big and generates
another one here four to four he was
definitely a slider and he did not miss
it and darnell with a chance to do
damage one man out two on
swinging a high fly ball deep to center
field retreating as sierra at the wall
it's
gone
three-run home run travis darneau
and the braves have seized control in
the bottom half of the seven dead center
braves with vicious high fives in that
dugout i mean it's like half the dugout
came out to greet him and why not so
here's dansby swanson seventh brave to
bat in the seventh inning and only one
man out points first pitch is hit hard
to center field in the air toward the
gap sierra going back looking up that
one's gone dansby schwarzer with a
two-run blast it's 9-4
welcome to the game james hoyt first hit
of the game for dansby swanson
and he smoked it to left center field he
sure did jim that might be the hardest
hit ball all day by anybody shift is on
for joyce 3-2 runners go and joyce
flares one towards swanson it gets down
for a base hit
anderson is in
rojas gets the hold sign at third and
matt joyce with a pinch hit rbi
to get miami back within four still two
on with two out here in the eighth
inning and the marlins are down to their
final out last chance aguilard
first pitch swinging deep to center
field acuna back at the track
acuna started it with a home run at the
bottom of the first he ends it with a
catch in the night all part of a nine to
five game one atlanta braves victory
over the miami marlins in this 2020 nlds